what's going on everybody welcome to
another Jenga web development tutorial
with Python in this tutorial we're going
to be talking about taking our website
and pushing it live to production at
this point we have a beautiful website
with just really high quality content
that would just make the world a better
place if it could just access our
content so that's what we're going to be
talking about here and so there are a
lot of ways to push a website into
production and let the public access it
you've got things from shared hosting
all the way up to just having your own
actual you know server or something
running out of your house so what we're
going to be using here is digitalocean
there are many other options you don't
have to use digitalocean
we are going to utilize digitalocean
mainly because digitalocean
offers a one-click install app for
django specifically there are a lot of
little things that we're still gonna
have to do after that but it will
significantly make the startup process a
lot easier to use digitalocean plus it's
fairly cheap it's $5 a month for the
smallest server but also you can pay
hourly and that's point seven pennies an
hour so really less than a penny to run
through this tutorial and then you could
close it if you wanted or or whatever so
we're going to using digitalocean if you
do not have a digitalocean account there
is a link in the description that's a
referral link it's if you want to
support me in the channel and all that
and you were already going to use the
joy lotion anyways you can use that link
if you want to stick it to me then I
suppose you you could not use the link
so anyway coming over here but why are
you watching anyway come over here and
once you sign into digitalocean that'll
be like a big green button in the top
right click that button and you'll be
brought here this is just create
droplets now normally what a droplet is
your virtual machine it's your VPS okay
so here are operating systems and you
can choose versions and stuff like that
but they also have these one-click apps
that I was talking about we're
interested in Jango on fourteen point oh
four so take that that's fourteen point
oh four is your operating systems going
to be Ubuntu version 14 point oh four
now after you're all said and done here
you you can upgrade to fifteen point oh
four or 1510 which is a
now you can do what you want but
starting at this point it's just going
to be really easy you're not gonna have
to configure a bunch of junk so choose
that then we've come down here and we're
going to go with five dollars a month or
a point zero zero seven dollars an hour
and then you've got a region I'm just
going to go with New York it really
doesn't matter but you kind of want to
think about like who your main users are
going to be and you want your server
located close to them if that's what
you're doing also if this is going to be
your actual if you plan to continue
using this I highly suggest you check
backups
it adds 20% to your monthly cost but
it's worth it it's worth it to have it
there things do go wrong things get
corrupted you accidentally move
something one time accidentally copied
like clicked and dragged my root
directory into some other directory I
don't even know what happened and I
could not fix that situation so I just
reverted to a backup is super easy I'm
not going to do it this is just a
tutorials website don't do it if you're
I feel like if you're just planning the
nuke this server later on but it's
definitely useful I've never regretted
having them I've only regretted not
having them finally the host name this
is the name of your server you can call
whatever you want I'm just going to call
it Django Tut's good enough so go ahead
and hit create there and I'm going to
move this aside while that's creating
and we can look at our beautiful website
yeah I'm actually gonna move this aside
well that's creating what you're going
to want to do is first of all it depends
on if you're on Windows Mac or Linux Mac
and Linux are basically the same as far
as SSH is concerned so if you're on Mac
or Linux you would you would su just
type in your terminal SSH and then the
username which for now would just be
root and then at and then the IP address
so let's say it's like one ninety two
five five twenty two thirty four twenty
two okay that's all you need to do if
you're on Mac or Linux if you're on
Windows that doesn't work you're going
to need something like putty so if
you're on Windows get putty okay
and that'll that's a that basically goes
to here you put in your IP address and
you're good to go so then so that's
putty if for transferring files like
just like so you click and drag file
you're going to want to be able to do
either SFTP or SCP you can also do SCP
via the command line I just really don't
like it it's actually easier for me to
use the GUI form so I prefer to use
winscp so if you're on Windows you can
use winscp FileZilla also works on
Windows and back and stuff like that so
get those two things and pause the video
while you're getting those by now your
website should be where your server
should be ready to go so I'm going to
move this stuff aside and let's see if I
got my email yet so when you sign up for
a digitalocean droplet server you should
be emailed and the email will contain
the new droplet name the IP address the
user name which will always be root and
then a password the first time you log
in it's going to make you change that
password so let's go ahead and log in so
I'm just going to copy and paste just
copy that IP paste it in here hit enter
wait for it my ticket maybe the server
maybe I was too quick the server might
not totally be ready if the server was
like literally just setup you kind of
want to wait like a minute or two let me
go see if it's up on digital ocean pause
this okay we're back so that probably
took let's see the the droplet was
created I'll just give you guys an exact
time that that took three minutes from
being created to when I could actually
connect okay so here we have this is
just a message basically any time you
connect to a server for the first time
it's going to send you the RSA these for
now RSA to fingerprint so if it's the
first time you've ever connected to the
server that's totally normal that's fine
you'll hit yes and continue on if it is
not the first time if you've been
developing on the server and then you go
to connect to it and suddenly the
fingerprint changed someone's something
hinky has happened and you need to
figure out what is going on it's
probably not good so keep that in mind
it's a new server don't worry about it
hey yes
so then you're going to log in here in
our case go back to your email your
username should be root and then they
emailed you the password if you're using
putty you should be able to copy just
copy and then you come over to the
terminal and just right click that
pastes it in you just can't see it but
right click that's good not sure if that
works on Mac or Linux someone can
comment below it should work on Linux
I'm not sure about Mac anyway hit enter
you should be fine there and then that
then you're logged in ok then again it's
going to force you to change that
password because that was just a
temporary password so again I'm just
right-clicking hitting Enter and now I
make a new password so my password is
cookies with an exclamation mark
protip don't tell anybody else your
server password ok so once you're
connected you're actually your website
should be live so if you go to your IP
address you can do this just copy this
and go paste that into a browser you
should see this and that should be a
pretty familiar message from you from
like one of the first tutorials when we
set up Jango so you should have that and
you should be happy to be seeing that
message now basically this is here
because we just have a really simple app
right now so what we're ready to do is
to begin moving our files over if you've
been following along you should have all
the files if you haven't been following
along for like whatever reason you
should you can go to Python programming
net come down to web development or come
over and then django and then right now
i don't have all of them up yet so
releasing them but you can come down to
each tutorial and at the bottom there's
the you can download the code so you can
go to part ten and just download the zip
file if you don't have the code or
something else is wrong so let me move
that aside and see so once you have that
code it should you can extract it and
you should basically have all this
information okay so we've got blog my
site personal the database and manage pi
so with that infrared e to go what
you're going to want to
do is pop over to SCP go ahead new site
and the hostname is your IP address if
you're on FileZilla same thing it will
ask for a hostname it'll be the IP
address for some reason that has changed
my protocol I don't want that I want to
be on SCP or SFTP on FileZilla I don't
actually think you choose that I'm
pretty sure the only thing you pick is
the port number
make sure has 22 that's a secured port
now user name what for now is root and
then my password is cookies exclamation
mark wait for it again this is the first
time we've connected with winscp so yes
wait for it again and you are in so now
what we can do is well I'll leave that
alone
we're now you're in the root directory
so with this one click install Jango is
installed back here so if you're on
winscp you can just kind of click back
to this little error or the forward
slash but you can also always go back so
like for example going back to where
oops that's the wrong one go back to
where we were like here you can always
just click these dots to go back to so
now we're in the root directory or the
main directory and django is hosted at
should be i think it's in home so home
yeah home django and then Django project
and then we'll come in to actually say
here so once you're on this page coming
over here this is our like website data
we're going to take blog my site
personal actually we're going to leave
my side out of this and we're actually
just going to take blog personal and the
database so take those and either you're
on FileZilla or winscp and just click
and drag them into the home django
Django project so click and drag those
in
and while waiting on that that should be
pretty quick it's just the initial stuff
will take a sec but while we're waiting
on that what's going to happen is
basically what have we done well we've
added new apps right so what's the first
thing we always have to do well we've
got to install the apps so clicking on
Django project here just double click
into that that's basically our site was
you know my site slash my site this one
click install makes it Django project
Django project so everywhere we have my
site we're just replacing with Django
project we could kind of flip that we
could change the core directories that
lead to or the core files that lead to
Django project either ones going to be a
lot of effort so this one's I think the
easier way to go plus this is what
you're more likely to do you're more
like if you're going to use someone
else's application you need to be
familiar with moving those over what
what's required to implement so once
you're in here we're going to go into
the settings pie and that's this file
here another pro tip I've set up before
but I'll say it again don't share the
secret key with anybody it's just in
this tutorial simply because it has to
be so making this big the first thing we
have to do is we have to install the app
so we come down here and if you remember
we had two apps we have a blog and then
personal ok save that the other thing we
have to do is if you come down here
we'll see that they're using a Postgres
database instead I'm going to replace
that we're using a SQLite so if you go
into your these are the files this is
the tutorial files leading up to this go
into my site and then the settings dot
pi let's go ahead and open that one up
and I'm going to move this aside we're
looking for the database this ok this is
your databases so we'll take that
copy/paste and we'll save that we are
going to come back in and how we have to
have one more thing but we'll come back
to that so go ahead and exit that and
I'm going to access this before I get
confused
and then we're going to open up URLs dot
PI and then again going back over to our
original website just go ahead and open
up that one we'll just copy and paste
them over so we need the URLs that point
to the personal dot URLs and the URLs
that point to the blog URL so let's move
this over coming over here paste and
then fix this okay
save that close out of that and let me
think here the next thing that we want
to do this one click install is first of
all it's on Django 14 point oh four for
example so you could do upgrade and
release and upgrade your actual
operating system that's not as important
but one thing to note is most likely
like type Python and then import Django
and then what you're going to want to do
is do Django dot versions are just make
sure y'all can see that Django version
and you'll see we're using one point six
point one we don't want to be using that
I mean it should be fine
but we're going to go ahead and update
that so quit and what we're going to do
is pip pip install - - upgrade Jiang go
ahead hit enter there and now we've got
one point nine point one we did see that
we got this syntax error but it looks
like it's still installed but we will
check just to make sure so python import
django and then Jiang
Django dot all caps version okay so now
we're pushing one point nine point one
great so we'll go ahead and quit not all
caps just regular okay so the next thing
that we need to do is we actually should
be good at this point let's go to our
web site
let's try refresh nope
nothing yet I'm trying to think if
there's something I've miss or if we
need to just restart let's see so go go
and do service G unicorn or actually the
CEO is this is the right IP
yeah jewnicorn restart we try to refresh
now if that did it
yeah okay so that's kind of like we're
starting Apache right so anytime you
make a change you might need to do that
but I'm pretty sure you only need to do
that if you've updated your like your
settings in like your maybe the URLs PI
and stuff like that you have to play
around with that but a lot actually
but it seems like Jango automatically
updates a lot more than flask from what
I found anyway once you've done that you
can refresh and boom you've got a lot of
things but you're actually you're still
missing a few things right our images
are gone and it looks like we're not
pushing any bootstrap right there's no
CSS here so moving this over we can go
over here and we're like hey what's
going on basically if you recall our our
CSS is supposed to be impersonal and
then static and then personal and then
we've got the CSS fonts image JavaScript
all that so normally it should work just
already but what we're gonna have to do
is two major things first what you're
going to want to do is you want to nano
slash etc' and then nginx and then sites
available and then django and what
that's going to do is is going to open
up your configuration for your django
application and coming down what you're
looking for is the Django project static
files directory in our case it's alias
to /home django Django project Django
project static take that in just ctrl C
to copy it you're just trying to copy it
and then go ahead we'll leave that up
for now coming over to you SCP go into
the main Django project Django project
settings PI edit and come down to
here we go static URL equals above that
we're going to add one thing that's
going to be a static underscore root
equals full quote paste home django
Django project Django project static
make sure that's in there we're going to
save that I'm going to exit out of that
we're going to come over here control X
do not if you added something don't save
it and then we're right now we're in the
root directory so you can do PWD to
figure out where you are
we're in slash root or the root user
directory where we want to be is home
django Django project Anka project right
we're actually home django django
project so change directory slash home
django django project if you're not
familiar you can start to types on the
hit tab and it finishes it hit enter and
now what we want to do is we want to run
Python managed PI collect static hit
enter and then basically it's just
telling you you're going to overwrite
some existing files are you sure you
want to do that yes says 73 static files
have been copied we'll come over here
refresh and now we have HTML CSS well we
already had HTML but we've got CSS we've
got our part our styling is here we can
bebop around we can open up stuff sort
database is connected so that's good the
final thing I want to show you guys is
right now right now by the time you see
this this will note not be hosted but if
you just happen to know I had it hosted
you could go to this IP address and
visit my web site the problem is that's
kind of lame like nobody actually has an
IP address as a website they've got a
domain name so I'm going to show you
guys how you can connect a domain name
to digital oceans so the first thing
you're going to want to do is wherever
you know you might have GoDaddy or I
don't know the other there's a billion
domain registrar's but go to whichever
you use
I'll show you domains
Google comm so I've got a domain on on
there well that's taken forever to load
and then we can click on one of the
domains and what you're looking for is
to configure the domain name server so
just looking at Google domains you can
come here and like this is your
configured DNS so that's your name
servers you can click on that and I'm
just making sure nothing that shouldn't
come up should come on okay so here's
your name service mine are already in
but if you're on like GoDaddy or
whatever the other hosts they're all the
same you configure name servers and
eventually you would say I want to use a
custom name server in my case since
we're hosting on digitalocean these are
the three name servers so if you're on
digitalocean use the exact same thing
it's NS 1 dot digitalocean comm and s 2
and n is 3 same things put those in and
then that can take I don't know how long
the cycle is on Google but usually that
can take up to 15 minutes to take effect
if you're changing name servers like if
you had name servers before and you're
changing them that can take like hours
and you may want to flush DNS on your
whatever machine you're using but that's
not we're talking about we're just going
to keep it simple for now that's the
first time it should take up to 15
minutes and you should be good once
you've done that basically what you're
doing is you're pointing this this is
you know cyber io
we're pointing that domain to the name
servers for digitalocean that's one step
the next step is on digitalocean saying
what we want to do with that domain name
so coming over to digitalocean you can
click on the networking tab at the very
very top and then click on domains and
the one I'm interested in is well
actually probably what you would do is
you would add a domain let me pull this
over so you would go to you've come
digitalocean here and you go networking
come down to domains and you'd add a
domain so in my case I already have one
added but you would basically just say
here you would say for my domain at
cyber
I oh it already exists and then you can
click here and you can either put in the
IP address or when you pick click that
you'll get a bunch of options of
droplets that already exist when you're
done you'll hit create record and then
you should have something that looks
like let me pull up the one that is for
cyber basically you'll create a record
and you'll see this okay and make sure
that's actually the correct IP for what
we're doing where's the websites 162 243
0 oh no it's not the right IP so let me
change the IP let me copy this page this
one might not this might not happen
eventually but anyway so for me I'm
actually changing the IP address for
this record because I already had one
before so you would put in here you
shouldn't have to do this though like
this should already be done for you if
you followed the other step at all
anyway I'll go ahead and save that and
it says it was updated let me see here
let's go to Cyberdyne items ok cool so
it actually already worked so I've tied
in that so really the thing that takes
the most time is point is actually
taking a domain from the domain
registrar and pointing it to specific
host name servers that takes a lot of
time especially if you're changing the
name service so if you changed hosts or
something like that but the once you've
done that part once that process is done
and if it's the first time it's usually
pretty quick but anyway once that's done
you go to your whoever your host is in
our case of a digital ocean and then you
set up the rest there so anyway that's
how you can tie like a domain name to
the actual website and everything else
should be done so anyways that's it for
pushing your website to production if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time